quand j'étais enfant, les
gars comme moi ont été élevés pour suivre les
vêtements
hey jerkle
[Musique]
que diriez-vous quoi
antonio soprano
je me demande si je peux vous parler seul
un instant mr soprano
sur la base du binet de sanford il est
haut  iq
tu ne peux pas le prouver par moi il a un d
plus moyen
eh bien il ne s'applique pas mais il est
intelligent
les résultats nous disent qu'il est un leader
cheville [ __ ]
[Musique]
grandir avec la famille
prend un péage peut-être un ambassadeur en
angleterre  pas de farces tu es mon neveu
je veux faire tout ce que je peux pour t'aider
mon cadeau pour toi
je veux aller à l'université je ne peux pas avoir d'
appelant merde comme ça
regarde tu prends les haut-parleurs en
même temps tu te dis  c'est la
dernière fois que je vole
quelque chose
c'est aussi simple
que ça laisse moi aller lui parler il n'écoute que
dickie
je dois faire quelque chose à propos de dickie
matasani
peut-être que certaines des choses que tu fais ne
sont pas la faveur de dieu
seulement par exemple
nous '  Je prendrai la bonne décision, ce gamin
a ce qu'il faut
aussi loin que toi  ouf va
je t'écoute
reste en dehors de sa vie
[Musique]
toi